une collision frontale entre un car
scolaire et une voiture c'est le
scénario de l'exercice nombreuses
victimes qui s'est déroulées mercredi
soir sur la nationale 10 à hauteur de
villechau contre Château-Renault et
Vendôme un test grandeur nature pour
apprécier la coordination des moyens de
secours et la gestion de crise sarrago a
pu y assister
il est 18h30 lorsqu'un car scolaire
percute une voiture sur la nationalité
15 minutes après les pompiers arrivent
sur les lieux les premiers blessés sont
évacués sur le bas-côté de la route
les 33 fausses victimes sont triées par
les pompiers et le SAMU selon leur état
elles sont réparties en cas de
catégories décédé
urgent absolu
urgence relatives et impliquée
au sol assez na et taximus une personne
en situation d'urgence absolue cette
étudiante de 18 ans est en première
année d'infirmière elle a décidé de se
porter volontaire bah en fait vu que
j'ai jamais été victime avant
là ça me permet de voir dans mon équipe
elle marche et tout on est tout et même
comment ça fonctionne comme on est
transporté quoi que ce soit
à ses côtés le sapeur-pompier Jérôme
chaloua pour lui c'est aussi une
nouveauté dans sa carrière il n'a jamais
été confronté à une situation de cette
ampleur c'est surtout intéressant parce
que c'est la qu'on se rencontre
finalement des choses qui faudrait faire
ou qu'il faudrait pas faire et puis
essayer de prioriser les choses quoi
dans la dans l'urgence quoi mais c'est
sûr que c'est très intéressant à faire
ouais afin d'anticiper au mieux la
gestion d'un tel accident routier la
préfecture de Loir-et-Cher organise
chaque année un exercice de ce type
il s'agit effectivement de coordonner le
travail entre tous les acteurs de la
sécurité civile et pour cela les
exercices réguliers sont très importants
mais également sensibiliser la
population au risque routier
particulièrement sur la route nationale
10 qui est très accidentogène sur ce
point qui était choisi pour cette raison
ici aujourd'hui
une opération nécessaire dans un
contexte de hausse de l'accidentologie
en France
3260 personnes ont perdu la vie l'année
dernière contre 294 en 2021